cyberpunk 2077 can't come soon enough
fortunately the fine people at arts
house Orion Games have finally released
the jump start kit to the long-awaited
tabletop RPG cyberpunk red-red is the
sequel to cyberpunk 2020 and cyberpunk
2020 as I'm sure you know by now is what
cyberpunk 2077 is based on that's a lot
of cyber pearl anyway if you do the math
there are about fifty seven years on
accounted for and cyberpunk read aims to
fill some of those gaps
[Applause]
now before we really dig in to read
here's a bit of background featuring the
creator himself Mike pon Smith the 20/20
world is a fusion of many types and
elements of the overall cyberpunk genre
it's about a combination of technology
gone wrong but being used by people in
novel ways up against large
mega-corporations powerful people and
powerful forces governments etc that are
all pretty much conspiring to keep
people oppressed and stomped on well you
can create any sort of cyberpunk city or
setting you like in the tabletop RPG the
books in the game focus on Knight city
and urban sprawl between Los Angeles and
San Francisco as pon Smith said
corporations are mostly calling all of
the shots and doing what they can to
keep the people suppressed while
government still exists they rarely pose
much of a threat to the corporate
overlords the lack of government
regulation has left the mega
corporations free to start conflicts on
a whim with little repercussions these
wars have been dubbed the corporate Wars
and typically end in lots of bloodshed
cyberpunk red takes place in 2045 after
the fourth corporate war a bloody
conflict started in 2021 by Aqua Corp
sino and otech and later escalated by
militant Arisaka as different
corporations aligned with either Arisaka
or Millett Eck all-out war was waged
between different corporations across
the planet the mega corpse rolled
through countries broke international
laws and hired private armies to do
their bidding in an attempt to end the
war Johnny Silver Hand aka Keanu Reeves
and the solo Morgan black hand led an
attack on the Arisaka headquarters in
night city during the raid a small
nuclear bomb detonated and leveled most
of night city killing over half a
million people despite knowing that the
bomb was supplied by military US
president put the blame on Arisaka and
nationalized millet X the increased
pressure reduced Arisaka to a japan-only
corporation for the next decade due to
the combined efforts of militant
national armies the fourth corporate war
was put to an end
the end of the fourth corporate war
assured in the time of the red so why is
it called cyberpunk red well due to the
mass destruction and radiation from the
fourth corporate wore a red Paul hangs
over the skies worldwide however the
radiation isn't that big of a threat
because most people living in the
universe already had a radiation filters
installed in their bodies with major
cities in shambles people have been
reclaiming the once abandoned towns and
settlements throughout the country as
you'd expect bandits and other
questionable types roam the wilds most
people who venture beyond the city stick
with armed nomads caravans meanwhile in
2030 sweeping reconstruction projects
take place across the world especially
in night city which had its city center
leveled however in the interim the city
outskirts and districts less affected by
the bomb have become overcrowded by 2045
the first mega building is erected these
are huge buildings designed to safely
house as many people as possible these
apartment in the 2077 gameplay revealed
demo is located in a mega building as
the narrator says in the video these
apartment buildings have everything one
could possibly need and typically form
micro societies within night city in
2045 night cities endcard subway system
has also seen better days
while it's functional flooding is a
common occurrence and gets delayed
frequently according to Red's world book
city planners are working to raise a
majority of the track into a new
monorail configuration but that will
take time and money the city doesn't
have something tells me this monorail
system will be complete by the time 2077
rolls around
to kick off this new era the net as we
know it or rather as we know it from
cyberpunk 2020 has been wiped out
originally you were able to travel the
world and into space via the net but the
infrastructure that allowed for that
kind of freedom has been destroyed after
the fourth corporate war net runners had
to physically jack into local networks
if they wanted access based on what
we've seen of cyberpunk 2077 I'd imagine
this localized net infrastructure is
still present in the 20 70s along with a
series of localised networks the time of
the red introduced citywide networks
called data pools these can be accessed
one of two ways through a data term or a
cell phone device called an agent from
what I can tell local networks rarely
interface with these data pools data
pools are essentially the Internet if it
was localized to a city you can message
people share information buy stuff and
research things ie Facebook forums
Amazon and Wikipedia all exist within
the data pool it's also home to
something called pop media which is
described as entertainment and news
programming created by independent
producers instead of mega Corpse
according to the world book and also
boasts an ungodly amount of trash sounds
familiar doesn't it chances are your
primary communication device in
cyberpunk 2077 will be your agent in
cyberpunk read agents come in three
forms basic expensive and luxury agents
can do pretty much anything a modern
phone can do except you can reprogram an
agent to act as a surrogate lover and
purchase other complementary cybernetic
enhancements to suit various needs
sounds like a sidequest waiting to be
written one what a fatty
I missed you baby sweet with the public
transportation system constantly on the
fritz cars were your most reliable way
of getting around during the time of the
read and while fancy cyber cars did
exist they were expensive and hard to
drive unless you were cyber DUP
fortunately good old fuel burning cars
are still around and kickin during read
while cyber cars might be rare cyber
bikes aren't these things can run off
alcohol or water and are definitely
present in 2077 to other vehicles
cyberpunk red mentions are the f-150 -
Aero gyro which is basically a one-man
helicopter and the mcdonnell-douglas a
v4 the a v4 is described as the closest
thing to a science fiction jet car these
are each speeds of three hundred and
fifty miles an hour and are typically
reserved for corporate bigwigs and
trauma teams if I were a betting man I'd
say that the aircraft we see at the
beginning of the gameplay reveal is one
of those considering CD Projekt RED has
said that you probably won't be able to
pilot flying cars or vehicles I think
it's safe to say that transportation
technology won't make too many
advancements before 2077 however I bet
we'll see more cyber cars hey give us a
lift out of here
and of course one of the most important
things for any cyberpunk is their style
however clothing does more for a
cyberpunk vennett them some clout on the
street depending on how much you're
willing to spend you can find jackets
with built in portable chargers clothing
with adjustable temperature body suits
that can change colors and textures and
undershirts that can harden into body
armor hopefully when 2077 comes out I'll
be able to give my net running Ninja
Assassin a body suit that lets her cloak
herself as she breaks into corporate
headquarters but what about Johnny
silver hand and morgan black hands wake
the [ __ ] up samurai we have a city to
burn well they should be dead but if
you've seen the III 2019 trailer it's
clear that Johnny is still alive at
least in some form according to the
cyberpunk read timeline there are rumors
that Johnny silver hands body was found
in cold storage in a body bank under the
wreckage this is just a wild speculation
but I hope we get to recover Johnny
silver hands body at some point during
2077
Morgan black hand on the other hand is
rumored to be covertly working for the
US government and president kress I'm
not exactly sure how he could play a
role in 2077 but based on the gameplay
reveal you can pick Morgan black hand to
be one of your characters role models
the cyberpunk grad jumpstart kit is out
now and this video only scratches the
surface if there's something I missed
feel free to drop it in the comments
below or you can find me on Twitter at
Jacob deck thank you all for watching
[Music]